h
okay uh yes i think we are
ready to go uh this is not
a uh normal banter blitz this
is a timeouts event i'll be playing 10
games against specific opponents
and in each of those games i'll have
two minutes against five and i'll try
to to yap a bit as well
as um as they as they do
uh and i think uh the first game has
already
has already been gone uh sorry been
started my danish opponents has made a
move
so i think i'll just i'll just get it
started
here e3 some move i played myself is a
bit of inoffensive
usually not in combination with knight
c3 okay let's go h5
let's try and uh
and uh punish this danish fella
it's a bit of a surprising choice there
bishop h3 and then
takes h4 don't know what that is all
about
okay we'll attack a bishop
and uh develop with tempe
now uh if you take back then
take the rook knight f3 is a good move
but it's uh
it's a piece up for me already okay we
go back
d5 develop
the pieces easy easy
f4 it's a bit of a belated attempt to
play the stonewall
but the stonewall is is not a
it's not very good a piece down
especially when you're missing the light
squared bishop which is covering a lot
of squares
yeah knight b5 don't
know if that threatens a lot knight b4 i
think is
a bit more dangerous now well i can even
take on c2
first since that's not actually
protected and it looks like my
opponent's position is kind of falling
apart here
so okay there's the mating two
okay uh so first game was
uh was easy enough
let's um let's get going for
uh another one
as soon as i can
[Music]
figure out the
uh the technical bits
so i've sent a challenge here
hopefully that will be accepted very
soon
uh
um
okay looks like i got myself an opponent
florian from
switzerland a little bit higher rated
so i assume this game will be a little
bit
more of a challenge or we'll we'll see
anyway the theme of the day is challenge
your brain and
i hope to be able to do that we got a
grinfeld
defense here a bit of a passive
variation from
from white here but nevertheless there
is
a reasonable choice um
sorry about that
here yeah um through castles
i'm just going to play a tarash
uh a temple down but the tarish is not
that great in opening so even being a
tempo down i should be
should be at least fine h3 i think we'll
see here
um otherwise bishop g4 comes
and usually in the tires the bishop is
an e2 or an e7
so yeah h3 is a good move i think
takes knight a5 is a typical plan
and then yeah when the bishop goes away
then i go bishop b6
knight g5 they're especially c4
very good player for my opponent so far
though
all the pieces on good squares
you know classical chess
so uh yeah knight t5 now i might lose e7
but i think i'll get to a2 back so
that's that's not an issue
and it may not look that great to trade
a
um flank pawn for central palm but i
think i'll
still have a good blockade over d5 so
i'm not that worried
yeah my opponent isn't spending a lot of
time which i think is
it's very reasonable
still got um sizeable time advantage
so now bhp7 i'll take on c1
and then rookie 8 or x8
probably rook c8
that not much to go on as to which one
is better
now we'll take an a2 and next probably
knight c6
to consolidate
maybe knight c4 also attacking b2
who knows but it feels like my position
is
is a bit better here
knight g5 is an option but maybe i can
just meet that very coolly with
bishop d5 uh and apart from that
i think knight c6 is a perfectly good
option though
well knight c6 there's bishop c3 which
is reasonably solid but it's still
fairly passive so i don't think i should
discourage it
rook d8 now putting pressure on d4 i
think h6 is reasonable preventing knight
g5 forever
yeah we'll go queen d5 threatening d4
and next probably i'll go a5 and then b5
try and kick the bishop away from c3
yes goodnight e5 though just a bit
annoying
it's actually really annoying
yeah that was uh not something that i
should have allowed okay
uh yeah this is
this was uncalled for um maybe i should
have gone
knight e7 there
but i i didn't didn't really love it
bishop c4 i'll go queen d6
and now i think queen b5
no queen b3 was my plan
this is just a blunder let's see if
you'll see it
this is this is a tough game really
tough game
yeah that's a good move
okay i'll take back
it wasn't that great to move though oh
this is not good
this is not good my opponent fortunately
for me has panicked here
no you could you could have taken back
sir
you could have taken back it was not
hanging
but still then i would have taken then i
would have gone b5 and a4 and i think
that
that pawn was unstoppable
bishop f4 now explaining some back rank
themes i will take
d-pawn is running but it's not running
very far
i guess we'll just exchange
the rooks because why not
we'll just run and the pawn is
unstoppable
okay uh and the end fairly
fairly comfortable um
but uh
the yeah it was uh
it was a little bit dicey there for for
a bit
um and uh for all those who are
challenging me to
to normal games um
that's not gonna that's not gonna happen
this time
um there will be there will be plenty of
other
opportunities for for banter blitz so so
don't
don't worry about this particular uh
event is
um uh
is for uh 10 players who have
qualified from from the app to to play
old schemes
bye
you
okay let's uh let's see
there uh an opponent has uh
has accepted my challenge
mr epic skills from india
that's probably jack richard
the name okay um
we'll get an elapin sicilian
very solid system for white
a bit of a think here like you should go
e5 that's the only
only good move here d4
this one is a little bit dubious i think
i'll take e4 and then i'll take the pawn
white does have some
compensation but i don't think don't
think it's uh
it's quite worth it especially now that
i'm
developing with tempe
oh why didn't i take the bishop
immediately
like you should certainly should
certainly take the bishop pair
when you can most of the time
at least when it comes like without any
particular
problems any any uh
no then you should just go ahead take
the bishop parent
ask your opponent what they got like
because you have a
long well in this case i have a pawn out
but usually like you have a long-term
advantage in terms of
the bishop pair and unless
there's a concrete reason then that's a
good thing
like there's to me there's not a real
discussion
of style whether you prefer knights or
bishops like bishops are just better
and then
of course the like the scale of
how much you value them they can they
can differ quite a lot but
in general bishops are are better and
i would say that even even in
in blitz where like knights are supposed
to be
supposed to be good even in blitz i find
that bishops are
generally superior but
that's just me okay so for now
i'm developing quite normally
my opponent has played quite reasonably
since
losing that pawn early on um but
um yeah it's definitely phasing an
optional struggle
a build battle okay
so now there's a concrete reason to give
up the bishop pair which is to
um decisively weaken my opponent's king
and besides there's some some tactics so
then
you shouldn't not be as undogmatic
you should not be as dogmatic that's to
say
that you never exchange your knife uh
sorry bishops for
nights but i'm just saying you generally
shouldn't
now it's a typical theme when the king
has no
no protection then the rook can
can help from the from the third
uh or in this case the sixth rank and
then
there's no defense against rook g6 now
also h4 comes in order to meet rook g6
with bishop g5
there is queen g4 check and then take
taking on
f3 with with um with the knights
and that's going to result in some
serious material losses
so
it's looking it's looking
pretty good for me okay king h1 but this
is desperation i'm just taking the
knight
and then knight on f3 is
unassailable
cannot be sailed
queen b1 don't know what that is all
about
there's queen e5 then king g2
let me see if i can calculate mate real
quick yeah then
root g6 queen d5 which d6 that's mate
okay could have gone for knight d2 or
something
just to win oceans of material
but i feel like it's
kind of cleaner to to go for checkmate
um yeah root t6 should be
should be good queen h2 takes h3 bishop
g6 then h6 was also
perfectly clean let me see there's no
mating one
no for this
okay good stuff good stuff
uh
okay so we got ourselves a really
serious opponent here in bombomato
uh giuseppe latieri i've played before
in the play live challenge a few years
ago so
good to see you still um
reactive on the play minus app
um okay let's go for g6
and uh in that case i had a hard time
winning
as as white when in the simul so now
with
timeouts this is not gonna be it's not
gonna be easy at all
okay let me just go for
um this complicated line
which isn't which isn't very good but
who cares
at least my my opponent is thinking
just a good thing
maybe this is not the order
who knows
yeah ed6 this i'm not too worried about
in general
okay
think i saw this somewhere
that you can just ud6 you can just go
knight h6 maybe here cd4 well cd4 those
bish b4 perhaps
i think this is reasonable enough but
like the claim you're making is that
um black's position is
sound after like let's say all the whole
center clears and i'm upon down uh my
bishops are
going to be great on the diagonals and
also also i might be
crushed by knight d5
while i was talking oh boy
yeah this could be really ugly
all that talk and so little substance
okay we gotta go f6 this is properly
ugly
yeah this is awful but we'll hope to
survive
my opponento is showing very little
respect
yeah knight d4 this is good of course
and um
and i'm lost of course but hoping to
solve some confusion here
maybe queens yeah didn't matter actually
okay
okay
i have some hope like my position is
lost but i hope
rook g7 and who knows maybe there are
some tricks
okay
yeah it's a good move
it's a really good move actually
it's rookie 5 which is pretty good i'll
have to take
knight g6 i'll take that rook f8
hopefully i try and fight that way
oh this looks a little suspicious
how can i how can i exploit it
this i have no clue okay we'll try this
rook g5
hoping for some knight g4
it's intense my opponent is
getting short on time and hopefully a
bit bit nervous
okay that's a good move
very good move
okay
still hoping for some some trickery
oh this doesn't work okay then we'll go
away
i have nothing here
no time
no time you can't
you can't think that long mister okay
we'll take
hope for some tricks
oh that's a good move
oh that was a terrible time scramble
none of us were very fast there okay
okay uh yeah tough tough tough game
i can't say i can't say i'm impressed by
my own play and
my opponent was just uh was just
crushing me there
for uh for a bit
okay okay
let me uh
let me see if i can get any more
opponents here
you
okay got ourselves another
opponent from
mexico
let's go for the old carrick on defense
knight f3 and cd5 that's a little bit
surprising
php2 is a little bit passive though
my opponent gives me the invitation to
grab a lot of space in the center and i
think i'm gonna say
thank you very much that is what i'll do
yeah this was well
yeah this is not perfect
i'll have to i'll have to admit that
now knight d2 and then c4
okay
okay oh f3 this is dangerous
c4 should have been played there gotta
use some more time buddy
because this is over
there's no salvation here
knight of two is a threat and if rookie
two there is knight h2
which is a knockout blow since there is
mate after
king h2 queen h4
yeah so rookie 2 was played let me just
see
quickly if there's anything better i
don't think so
just take h2
and there are lines now like knight f3
then i can for instance take on f1 queen
f1 then queen h4 check
knight takes rook takes f1 king h2 and
then take the
the bishman c1 don't know if that's the
best but i thought it was the
cutest way to win
and not only is my opponent a piece down
here
but they're also still serious issues
with
coordination and
the king okay we'll just grab
it's a little bit dull but and it's
precise but we'll just
grab and reconnect a1 is threatened
so or
rather trapped okay take
now after king g1 i could take on t3 but
i feel it's rather more
thematic just to
keep that little pin
uh yeah knight f3 i think i'll go rookie
eight
and uh this should be made very very
soon
yeah bishop c5 and now rookie two
is made it would have been made after
bishop d4 as well that's why i promoted
it
okay yeah that was uh
um yeah i gotta you gotta think a little
more in the
in the opening there because um
otherwise you could you could
blow your chances very quickly
yeah um
okay uh looks like we have another game
from
a person from a prove a peruvian
uh
so let's see if this game is gonna it's
gonna start soon
okay so we got e3 again
why not
this time i'll grab some some space in
the center
well c4
is d4 an option here
no i don't think so okay we'll play it
simple then
no reason to spend 15 seconds on it but
then again once
okay we got ourselves a pretty normal
queen's gambit type of
line um and
in those lines e3 is not the most usual
but it's a perfectly reasonable way to
play
yeah it's kind of trying to provoke e45
don't think it's too great probably not
too bad either though
oh queen c1 that could very well be a
mouse slap
follow queen c2 was the intention there
to protect e4
but yeah
that's that's the way it goes sometimes
now of course i'm blown up with a
very very healthy position
probably rook c8 here
maybe going c5 later on also bishop d6
followed by
uh okay we should just bishop d5 then
shouldn't allow knight e5 for no reason
whenever an id5 comes i think i'll just
take it with the knights
uh bishop t 392
okay i gotta play a bit faster
i'm really getting caught up in
and just um in hesitation
okay this is quite reasonable i'll i'll
just
trade it off
my opponent is playing very well though
i have to say since blundering upon
early on it's kind of
playing better than i am okay
knight of six oh bishop b7 is an issue
didn't see that at first
i'm still very slightly better but i'm
no longer upon up
okay so we'll go h5 now
yeah this is going to be it's going to
be a tough game to win
not at all easy
i think we'll just go f6 and then
activate the king
try to get king f sorry king g4
rook yeah roxy one is good
active defense
rick c7 though
yeah that's true
i'm actually getting outplayed
oh rook f5 mile slip
rook f6 there and yeah i had to go
g5 maybe but i was certainly i was
certainly a bit worse there
or probably a lot worse already okay
now it's of course
now it's of course completely winning
for me
and should be plenty of time
should be made in two here
okay i'm not gonna bother to try and
find it
so we'll just take the maiden three
rook c3 or roxy one
okay very very tough game my opponent
played incredibly well there for uh
for a while except for
for a couple of mouse slips see ya'll
play me
which is uh pretty pretty impressive
so are we missing i think i can make it
easier for you like an erase stone soup
plate
is that easier
those are the ones left right yeah this
should be true
great stuff great stuff i guess you can
also mention that those who are playing
they are winners from the play magnus
app
so you should download the app because
we will definitely have more
competitions will you have a chance
yeah that's that that's true that's true
uh yeah
that's uh these are all um
uh all the people who are playing here
have played uh played a bunch in the app
so we're
very very happy with them with that of
course
uh okay
he had spelled his name wrong so i can
uh
oh i cannot do that i'm sorry
there we go okay
oh there we go there we go
okay we have another
challenge here um going out so i think
game is hopefully hopefully gonna start
very very soon
just okay
just some attention
yeah sorry people some some waiting time
here
just um
okay little challenge
okay not possible
oh there we go now i think
i'm gonna get a game soon
yeah usually i'm the one who has to
accept challenges but now i am begging
paying the people in this particular
challenge
to please accept my challenges
otherwise we're going to be here for
for a very long time
you
okay it looks like nobody's accepting my
challenges with it which is a bit
which is a bit annoying come on people
we gotta get the show
we're gonna get this show going
oh there we go we have a game
finally alexander milinovic sweden
from germany apparently okay we got
ourselves a game
it's one of the qualifiers from from
merck who are uh sponsoring this event
okay there we go one e4
a beautiful sight
oh a gambit this is going to be
interesting
94 that's surprising can't i take an e4
then
i'm hoping i can
i don't immediately see why not
oh this is no good
okay so yeah no
d5 moves that attack the queen attack a
bishop
and develop your pieces those are
usually good
that's the kind of wisdom you tune in
for
i would say uh and
now a night has uh has dropped
and um it's all looking very rosy
for me
uh okay bishop d5 there you can take it
c2
keep it simple and uh
i'm also sending a little trap which is
castles
runs into 92 with a fork
on the queen and the king rook f1
i don't think that's a lot better
it could be that my opponent is
not used to playing on online and try to
to castle this way
either way
didn't really work out okay i'll go b6
then bish basics try and
checkmate this way
okay rook d1 i don't think that helps at
all
which base6 not king f3 is the only move
then i'll think i think i'll just take
on d1
and um the end
will be quite near
okay
take if king e4 oh king e4 is the only
move queen e4 there's queen d3
king e5 hd6 checkmate
and i said yeah those seem to be the
only
legal moves that my opponent can make
okay yeah it was an interesting
opening from from my opponent but then
queen g4
sort of messed up the whole game in one
move which was a bit unfortunate
and then after that it was it was very
difficult
okay so i think we have uh
we have three games to go
if um if everybody's here
and we'll try to
send some some challenges
okay finally we have torqued
from singapore this is just a norwegian
called turkey
that would be funny but who knows
okay let's assume my opponent is
norwegian and play the scandinavian move
the queen
queen away and
start developing the pieces
a3 b4 to come perhaps i'm
preparing to drop the queen back then
yeah this is a little bit passive my
opponent is doing
it's perfectly reasonable but
nevertheless the best bit passive
okay now we don't have to move the queen
away but i think we will
and then we'll just castle
and there's nothing wrong
with my opponent's position at all
but i certainly
certainly did not experience any
particular
problems and this i'm
trying to change the structure a bit
don't know if this was actually
too brilliant okay let's try and be
thematic exchanging this one then b5
and thinking of knight b6 to c4
before that i certainly will jump in
this my opponent is playing very fast
and his
opponent is position is only a little
bit worse
so i gotta say it's been a it's been a
success for my opponent so far
okay i think we'll
take this square when i have the chance
don't know if my opponent should have
allowed that
now changing queens is not
the most obvious choice when you have to
to win with little time but i think it
makes the position sort of sort of
easier to navigate
and now i think my opponent needed to go
bishop d2 there first
because now there is no way to maintain
the structure
like this runs into rook a6 and then
rook a5
and i think inevitably i'm going to win
a pawn
um obviously it's going to be it's going
to be tough to win still though
okay this was uh
probably not ideal c4 was a good option
there
yeah my opponent is playing very well in
general
let me see for his options still here
why haven't i gotten bishop d6 okay now
that i
playing quite sloppily in this game
okay this was no good my opponent should
not have allowed me to get a
passport there in in a pure bishop's
ending
so now it's in it's an automatic win
yeah push bay 3 would only
be good if somebody had pre-moved
because the pawn ending is very very
very very simple
[Music]
okay yeah uh
good game very very decent play for a
long time there for my opponent
okay so two games to go
now hopefully yeah
they're my opponent this right on right
on cue
love that and then
um hopefully we'll
get a couple of interesting games trying
to play the sicilian this one
specifically the night earth
now let's see what my opponent will go
for
okay we'll go for the
classical night or setup
not
okay knight of three that's a good line
often with bishop g5 to come
rookie one it's a little bit surprising
to me
we'll go h6 just to be able to
play bishop e6 without any without any
worries and also
not allow g5
i might be walking into some knight h4
stuff though
not sure h3 is very reasonable
often connected with the plan of knight
h2 and then
knight g4 fighting for trying to
exchange the knight and fight for the d5
square
d3 i'm not too sure about
yeah this i don't think is very good
because the c3 square is very weak now
like you you would love it if the white
pawn
wasn't c4 but now now
um there's a there was a target on c3
and
this i don't think works for him
tactically
seems like i could just win a pawn this
way
maybe knight e4 was possible there as
well
there was some bish uh sorry knight x
e7 queen tax c7 and then bishop takes a6
perhaps
i didn't really want to get into that
now he does have
some compensation with the bishop pair
and a
fairly harmonious position after let's
say c4
but i don't think it's it's it's enough
maybe speaking of the bishop here maybe
i'll i'll get that off the board
actually
knight c3
forcing the exchange of one of the
bishops
and although of course
opposite colored bishops have some
drawing tendencies
unless you can establish a quick
blockade over
the light squares in the center then i'm
doing
very very well
knight d2 syllogical move
intend english path three knight d2 i
will perhaps
perhaps go for f5 trying to
control control some squares
although then that was knight f1 it's
not so clear
actually after
yeah roxy one i just go back
it seems it seems that i should be able
to
to consolidate here um
yeah okay after rook c2 i'll actually
just go d5
and um
and e4 i think
the thing is i'm not so worried about
losing
i'm not too worried about losing that
pawn on d5
since it was sort of
sort of in the way there
now i was hoping that he was gonna fall
for this trick since i think
i think bish b4 should win now hello
hi and uh
um yeah there's there's a pin the knight
cannot be
protected and if knight c4 there is roof
takes c4
take an e1 and now
i'm a knight up and this should be
this should be easy enough
queen c5 looks clean forcing the
exchange of queens
or take an e4 but then i'll take on f2
so that
doesn't really bring him a whole lot of
joy
and after queen c5 knight takes c5 i
have a lovely blockade
over his pawns and besides i have
i have an extra extra knight
it's all all very rosy at the moment
there g6 bishop c8 i'll go bishop e5
just to block everything now
to make matters even worse my opponent
has
trapped his own bishop very
unfortunately
and uh yeah there's there's not a lot of
hope here
okay uh yeah uh
good game there just one one or two
tactics
that that was missed but those things
those things happen of course um
okay so
that means that we have
one game left
and um
let's just hope that han azam
is here and ready to accept a challenge
come on
let's get this party started
you know you want to
you know you want to accept that
challenge
oh there we go okay last
last game of the day let's make it a
good one
okay 24.
let's go for the alien defense this time
just vary my traces a bit
okay knight of knight c3
usually of course white goes t5 there
oh my opponent disconnected
come on
come back
let's get a real game here
yes looks like a reconnect
okay e5
different choices are knight e4 97
d4 i go for knight e4
why not knight c to e2
is the best move here and then
there are a bunch of options like
f6 i think f6 is possible
it's a little bit it's a little bit
suspicious though
probably more than a little bit
okay after takes takes i'm pretty happy
um since
the yeah
the um e4 e4 and e5 bonds were
probably about equally weak
and uh now now i'm getting some
some pressure on the center immediately
probably h3 was a good move there
then if bishop h5 there's e6
um throwing a bit of a spanner into
works
and uh otherwise
if bishop f3 queen of three knight e5
queen b7 i don't think that would have
been any
any good for me e6 i don't really
understand it just seems to give up
the pawn for preciously little
no not even going to exchange queens
just very clean pawn up here i think
with uh
with the relatively uh
few weaknesses as well
oh 94 sorry dude
that night oh
well that is challenging my brain i
cannot understand the rationale behind
that move
what well
i'll accept the gifts of course
first the queen and then the knights
gonna be a queen and a knight up
and with those odds i'm usually quite
good
oh i don't i don't get any any of the
moves here
now he's disconnecting
ah that's no good that's no good
come back and let's let's finish this
off in a in a proper way
okay
good good good
hello a lot
a lot to think about here
hello magnus can you hear us
yeah magnus nice experience to play with
you
um yeah i hope i'll meet with you
one day and play with you in official
tournament
and congratulations magnus for winning
the knowledge to zero
to zero
okay so looks like we're nearing the end
here
um yeah nice little
nice little mate into here bishop cannot
uh sorry the queen cannot be taken
because of the pin
and then queen g2 will be
the case of death
uh okay uh
yeah that was a little bit rocky at
times
but uh finally a
uh um
yeah finally a few decent games
especially one
where i was struggling quite a bit and
easily could have lost um but
yeah thanks thanks to to to
play my nissan to turmeric and also
thanks to
to everybody who spent a lot of time on
the time of the app
and participated in this event it's it's
greatly appreciated thank you thanks
magnus for playing with us